[Music]
it is the best-selling book in history
no volume ever written has been more
loved and quoted and its words sometimes
simple and sometimes mysterious should
always be studied carefully it is the
Bible the Word of God welcome to Bible
answers live providing accurate and
practical answers to all your Bible
questions this broadcast is a previously
recorded episode to receive any of the
Bible resources mentioned in this
broadcast call 885 6 7 4 7
once again that's 800 eight three five
six seven four seven now here's your
host from amazing facts international
pastor Doug Batchelor hello friends
would you like to hear an amazing fact
in 2018 a Canadian mining company rnc
minerals hit an extremely rich vein of
gold in Western Australia in just over a
week they extracted over 577 pounds of
high-grade gold from a hundred and
thirty tons of material dug from deep
underground to understand the
magnificence of this strike one 200
pound gilded quartz rock they dug up is
estimated to contain a hundred and fifty
pounds of gold worth almost three
million dollars now that's a lot of gold
it makes one wonder how much gold is
still left in the world to be discovered
the World Gold Council estimates that in
the last five thousand years humans have
mined roughly a hundred and ninety
thousand metric tons of gold roughly 70%
of the global supply that would be
accessible twenty thousand metric tons
came from just the California Gold Rush
that means about 30 percent of the
world's gold has yet to be discovered if
you plan on finding some you better get
started pretty soon because according to
the US Geological Survey because of
modern mining technology it's so much
more efficient 80 percent of all the
gold ever brought above ground was mined
since 1910 and about 50
of all the gold ever mined has been
mined since 1967 did you know the Bible
says that if you've got the Word of God
you have something infinitely more
valuable than gold stay with those
friends we're going to learn more on
this edition of Bible answers live
[Music]
you're listening to Bible answers live
accurate and practical answers to your
Bible questions welcome listening
friends do Bible answers live and if you
have a Bible question we have lines open
this is a live international interactive
Bible study I think last week we had
calls from about three different
continents and you can listen from
anywhere in the world a lot of people
are shut down and so we've just had
tremendous listening audience lately
here's the phone number eight hundred
four six three seven two nine seven yes
we have lines open eight hundred four
six three seven two ninety seven we are
also streaming on Facebook and that
would be the Doug Batchelor Facebook
page or the amazing facts Facebook page
and again the phone number to call and
if you're in North America is 800 God
says 800 four six three seven two nine
seven with your questions about the
Bible or living the Christian life my
name is Doug Batchelor my name is John
Ross good evening friends and pass today
as we always do let's start with prayer
dear father we thank you that once again
we have this time we don't want to take
it for granted but we are grateful for
this time to open up your word and study
let me ask that your spirit would be
with us here in the studio Sacramento be
with those listening Lord across the
country and in different places around
the world Lord the purpose of this is to
cut the clear understanding of your will
for our lives and a clear understanding
of your word so we ask your blessing in
Jesus name Amen amen oh pastor day you
know probably back as young as a you
know a little kid growing up they've
learned to value gold it's the treasure
hidden by pirates it's goal is the most
valuable mineral or material on earth
and of course that's been carried on
from generation to generation for
hundreds of years
have been hunting gold searching for
gold you know that great find of
Tutankhamen and there was so much gold
in that tomb his whole face matthew
coffin e gold it just seemed like it was
it must have taken a lot of mining
especially in those days to try and find
that much gold yeah it's amazing
of course you're from south african i
went on a tour of one of the deep mines
they've got there i think the deepest
mined in the world is in south africa
and yeah people have been pulling that
it's an extremely unusual metal
extremely durable and so it's been
valuable it's been a staple for years
and even in the Bible it talks about
gold and not any gold it talks about the
gold even in Genesis the gold of Ophir
and the fine gold that Solomon got from
his mines presumably somewhere in North
East Africa they're not sure where that
was and that might be why several bible
writers compared gold to the word of god
and you can read for instance in psalm
119 king david said one verse 127
therefore I love your Commandments more
than gold yes than fine gold you know
people will huh don't break into houses
and rob to get gold and people would go
to great lengths to search the deserts
to find gold but what about the gold in
God's Word look at Psalm 19 verse 7 the
law of the Lord is perfect converting
the soul the testimony of the Lord is
sure making wise the simple and you read
down it says more to be desired are they
than gold yea than much fine gold
sweeter than the honey in the honeycomb
and you know the Word of God changes
people's lives it changes people's
hearts and it doesn't matter how much
gold you have if you're not happy all
the gold in the world it's not gonna
change it if you don't have eternal life
you can't buy that and that really comes
from the Word of God so there is a
greater treasure in the Word of God than
anything in the world you know pastor
like you write gold is very valuable but
there are two tables of
don't that today would probably be more
valuable than a lot of gold if it was
found and of course those two tables are
stone that we talking about written by
the finger of God is the Ten
Commandments we believe hidden somewhere
in the area close to Jerusalem in a
golden box in a golden box but the
stones are far more valuable that's
right on the outside of the ball good
point and we have a lesson that talks
about that treasure and we are gonna
send that treasure to anyone who wants
real gold I should say something worth
more than real gold for free now listen
it's called written in stone and yes
it's about the Ten Commandments and this
is a great study it'll start in Genesis
goal the way through the Bible
illustrating the importance of God's law
and how we can have the law written in
the heart we'll send it to anyone who
calls and ask the number if you'd like
to receive that he's eight hundred eight
three five six seven four seven that is
our resource phone line and just ask for
the study guide one of our classic
amazing facts guides it's called written
in stone we'll send it out to anyone who
calls and asks in that North America and
of course we also want to greet our
friends or watching on Facebook you can
see the number on the bottom of the
screen eight hundred eight three five
six seven four seven that is to our
studio if you have a Bible question the
phone lines are filling up fast so we're
gonna go to our first caller we've got
the Ashton listening in Kentucky Ashton
welcome to the program doing good thank
you for calling yeah yeah my question
was like it's like okay so like kind of
like how do you get like back on track
with God I say like because like I was
like leading a pretty good life I mean
you know before this I wasn't but after
it I was you know praying I was you know
reading my Bible and I was doing all
that stuff you should do you know I was
even sharing my faith but then I guess
somewhere along the lines I stopped
doing one of those things and I just I
just noticed one day I just woke up it's
like like crazy I just looked at my life
and I was like shoot like how do you get
back on track with God well that's a
great question Ashton there's probably
others out there that are wondering the
same thing we
we had a rich experience for the Lord
and then it seems like it drifted first
of all don't be discouraged because as
in life the Christian life can sometimes
feel like you're doing two steps forward
and one step back and jesus said in his
letter to the churches and I think it's
the Church of Ephesus the first letter
he said if you lose your first love you
repent and you return in other words you
go back to the spot where you lost track
of God and get a start there again you
know have a renewal of that commitment
it may mean getting on your knees again
confessing your sins say lord I want to
renew my covenant to accept you as my
savior please forgive my sins forgive me
for becoming distracted and believe that
he forgives you and then start doing
Jesus I do the first works again meaning
read the word scheduled that time and
say Lord tomorrow all right you can
begin right now actually I'm gonna have
a new beginning I'm gonna have that
regular time with you the prayer time
the quiet time I'm going to pray about
opportunities to share my faith and once
you know that he's forgiven you and
given you a new beginning it'll put joy
in your heart mm-hmm and you know I
would encourage you to find a resource
that kind of help you in your Bible
study sometimes it can be a little
daunting to take on a Bible and say well
where do we start so if you haven't even
done the amazing fact study guide
lessons it's a great guide to help you
dealing with some very important topics
and of course we'll send this to you
action for free you can call our
resource phone number and just say I'd
like to enroll in the amazing facts
Bible School and we'll do so the number
is 883 five six seven four seven and
again ask for the amazing facts study
guides series next caller that we have
is Darrell listening from Arizona
Darrell welcome to the program hello hi
thanks for calling Darrell thank you for
taking my call I just have a question
regarding biblical marriage and what
what is biblical marriage I guess
well are you wondering biblical marriage
does it need to be a state sanctioned
marriage or are you wondering you know
is it wrong to marry someone out of
faith all right so you're asking about
technically what would be a legally
biblically sanctioned marriage you know
in the beginning of course it says God
creates Eve from the rib of Adam and he
presents her brings her to the man and
they you know so the first wedding
service you might see is conducted by
God then a marriages sometimes were
contracted and you've got where you know
Abraham sends a servant and he contracts
a marriage of Rebecca with Isaac and it
says Isaac took Rebecca and she became
his wife they maybe didn't have some of
the ceremonies that they had by the time
you get to Jacob they're you know
they're having a seven day marriage
feast now the important components in a
marriage to make it legal was there was
a covenant because it's a lifelong
commitment it's a covenant that was
legally recognized meaning in your
society you don't want people going
after your husband or your wife so there
was a public announcement it was public
vows and people basically knew these
people are committed to each other hands
off they're not on the market anymore
and and so it was important that it was
public also so that they were the ones
responsible for their children so for a
marriage to be legal you know I think it
should be recognized by the laws of the
land and I've met a lot of people to say
well we're married in God's eyes and
that's all that matters and I always
come back wondering well what prevents
you from making it legal so I don't know
is that answering your question Darrell
yes you actually said the exact same
thing that I said this is regarding my
son and so I said the same thing and so
I it sounds sounds like we're on the
same page yeah I remember counseling
with a couple and they were living
together and said well yeah we're
Christians we're married in God's eyes
as well it hasn't been legal listen no
but it's in God's eyes I said now if you
guys decide to have children and you
separate will you need a divorce
and I said well no we won't mean we
don't need a legal divorce because it
wasn't a legal marriage I thought well
then you're not married so you know
people they spend all kinds of arguments
but there's no good reason for people
not to be legally married you know we do
have a study guide called keys for a
happy marriage yes I was just kind of
looking through it here online great
resource it's got some great points to
help any marriage to become stronger or
better and we'll be happy to send this
to anyone who might call and ask the
number again is eight hundred eight
three five six seven four seven and you
can answer the study guide it's called
keys for a happy marriage we've got
let's see Dennis listening in California
Dennis welcome to the program all right
thank you
hey thanks for calling it seems the
Abraham asked the blessing from God on
Ishmael and God gave it
yes additionally and he said for Isaac
you know this time next year you'll have
and he will be the child of the Covenant
and I'm thinking a covenants like a
contract which is kind of a you do this
correctly and then I'll do that
correctly you'd be good and I'll bless
you and it's kind of the Covenant or a
contract it's kind of an if thing you
know and I guess we can get corrected
over and over and over over and over
again but it seems like God blessed the
Moslems unconditionally
well now let's let's talk about that for
a moment when God said that he was gonna
bless Ishmael he did and he blessed him
with many children you know the blessing
of Abraham
and he had no children and God said look
I'm gonna I'm gonna bless you with many
seed not only through Isaac but through
Ishmael because he would have twelve
sons and that's in the same verse here
Ishmael had twelve princes it's
interesting Jacob had twelve sons too
but the Muslim religion the religion of
Muhammad and Islam was not part of this
blessing or there's no covenant that he
with a new religion because the majority
of the Muslims in the world they're not
they're not Arabs they're not related to
Ishmael they're actually in Indonesia
right now so God was not blessing a
religion that would be in conflict with
the religion of Christ so the blessing
of the Covenant that he was giving
through Isaac was that the Messiah the
savior of the world was going to come
through the line of Isaac from Isaac on
through Jacob through Judah through
David ultimately through Christ no such
blessing was given through any other
nation so God did bless Ishmael he gave
him a long life he gave him many
offspring and he prospered him but it
wasn't a blessing that the truth was
going to come through him is the lira
darrell no I'm sorry Dennis caused me to
wonder maybe they seem to be closer in a
way
well there's yeah there's some
commendable things yeah there are
commendable things in many religions you
know and you've got pastor Ross and I've
been to Indian African we we've seen a
lot of very devout Hindus that pray a
lot and make great sacrifice and go on
long pilgrimages and they're very
sincere and so I don't question the
sincerity of any other religion I will
question that the truth of it I mean do
they have a messiah that saves us from
the sins
the world but it takes on himself the
sins of the world there's nothing in
Islam or Buddhism or Hinduism that
offers that but yeah God did bless the
offspring of Ishmael you know you do
have a series of sermons pastor Doug on
Christianity Islam and yeah I forget the
exact title of it but I'm sure you can
prophesy Christianity Islam in prophecy
that's right it's a good resource next
one that we have is Barry listening in
New York Barry welcome to the program
all right thanks for taking my call my
question is this the Bible says that
when Christ returns the dead in Christ
shall rise and believers that are left
on earth will be caught up with them in
the clouds my question is who's going to
be around to participate in the thousand
years of paradise earthy emeriti of
millennium so you're asking a great
question you're wondering who is still
on earth during the 1000 years right
maybe pastor also find that Jeremiah
4:23 for me and we'll read something to
you there's a major misconception that a
lot of evangelicals make about the
millennium they assume that the
righteous are living on earth during the
millennium when in reality the Bible
says when Jesus comes back and I can
tell you're thinking on the same lines
when Jesus comes back we are caught up
Christ says I go to prepare a place I
will receive you unto myself that where
I am and these mansions that have been
prepared there you might be also so we
go up and the Millennium begins when
Christ comes so who's down here on earth
if the wicked are destroyed by by
Christ's coming well here's the verse
Jeremiah kept before verse 23 this is a
prophetic passage and it says I'll
beheld the earth and lo indeed it was
without form and void and the heavens
they had my light now someone might
think always talking about creation but
you could read on I'll beheld the
mountains and indeed they trembled in
the hills they moved back and forth I'll
beheld indeed there was no man and all
the birds of heaven had fled away I'll
beheld indeed the fruitful land was a
wilderness all the cities were broken
down by the presence of the Lord and by
his fierce anger for thus saith the Lord
so here we have a description of what
happens when Jesus comes
the earth is left in a broken-down or
desolate condition all the righteous are
in heaven the wicked are destroyed with
the brightness of Christ's coming and
the devil and his angels are sort of
bound to this earth Revelation chapter
20 talks about this bottomless pit the
word they pastor Doug is just abussos
meaning without form and void kind of
broken down now at the end of the
millennium though the wicked are
resurrected for the final judgment call
it the great white throne judgment you
read about in Revelation 20 also in
Revelation 21 yeah and you can there's
another scripture and it says in Isaiah
chapter 24 verse 3 the land will be
utterly emptied and utterly plundered
for the Lord has spoken Jeremiah says
that the slain of the Lord cover the
Earth from that day from one end to the
other and there's no one to lament or
mourn or bury them so several prophecies
describe a condition of the world where
it's vacated so during the 1,000 years
we're in heaven and the saved are living
and reigning with Christ the rest of the
Dead the wicked they're not living until
the thousand years are finished
there's nobody live on earth does that
make sense Barry the Millenium isn't
going to take place on earth it's not
going to become a paradise and be
restored
no we'll be in paradise with God and
then at the end of the 1,000 years the
New Jerusalem you read in John and
revelation 21 comes down to earth and
God then creates a new heaven and a new
earth and we have a lesson a free lesson
that covers us that I think will really
help you yes I'd encourage you to get it
it's called a thousand years of peace
and it's all about the Millennium
revelation chapter 20 and some other
very important passages we'll send this
to you Barry for free that I'm gonna
call he's eight hundred eight thirty
five six seven four seven eight hundred
eight thirty five six seven four seven
as for the study guide it's called a
thousand years of peace you can also go
to the amazing facts website it's
amazing facts dot ROG and you'll be able
to read right there about the 1000 year
period as well thank you for your call
our next caller that we have alternate
listening in Louisiana AlterNet welcome
to the program thank you
yeah how can we help your question
clarity on this scripture here is coming
out of Matthew 18 she after they first
barely I say unto you whatsoever you
shall bind on earth shall be bound in
heaven and with soever you shall loose
on earth shall be loosed in heaven
well things that happen here on earth in
sharing the gospel in in not sharing the
gospel in decisions that are made have
eternal consequences in heaven and Jesus
is saying that you know the the work
that we do here is going to have an
everlasting result and whether we share
the forgiveness of Christ or we forbear
doing that that's gonna have eternal
consequences and of course if you read
the context just a few verses above it's
talking about a situation that would
arise in the church where you might have
somebody who is claiming to be a
Christian but they're not living
according to the principles of the Bible
maybe they are causing conflict in the
church and there are certain ways in
which you need to deal with it
one of which is you need to go to them
you need to pray with them encourage
them you need to bring someone with you
but finally if they still refuse you
bring to the church and the church
appeals to them ask them to come to a
point of unity and reconciliation if
they still flatly refuse then it is
appropriate to at times separate them
from fellowship with the church now it
doesn't mean that they can never return
or never be saved but we need to
recognize that it's part of the
redemptive process where there are times
where we might have to correct people at
least try to work with them as much as
possible to bring them to an
understanding of truth then Jesus says
whatever you bind on earth will be bound
in heaven so he's emphasizing the
authority and the work of the church
when it's trying to win somebody back
yes thank you so much all right Thank
You Alton I appreciate it
we've got Kate listening in Brooklyn New
York Kate welcome the program hi good
evening bastards thank you for taking my
call I have a question regarding
Revelation 20 and it says whosoever was
found was not found written in the book
of life was cast into the lake of fire
so um I understand there will be two
groups of saved people one before
thousand years of peace and another
after thousand years of peace so my
question is does it mean those who say
it before thousand years are only
Christians and after thousands of years
after final judgment those are kind of
mix of Christians and non-christians am
i correct
thanks so much thank you for your
question Kate you know I think there may
be a little misunderstanding here
there there's only one group of saved
and lost the saved and lost are
separated at the second coming after the
second coming there's not another group
that God saves later all of the saved
that are alive are transformed and given
new bodies when Jesus comes all of the
saved who are dead are resurrected with
their glorified bodies when Jesus comes
we go back to heaven and we live and
reign with him in that celestial
paradise the New Jerusalem in heaven for
a thousand years at the end of the 1000
years the wicked are then resurrected
and I forget what verse revelation 22
verse 5 it says the rest of the dead
don't live until the thousand years are
finished meaning the rest of the dead do
live after that and if all the saved go
up when Jesus comes the rest of the dead
must be all the lost so they are raised
for a judgement and it says that they go
up on the breadth of the world led by
Satan it calls him Gog and Magog but
that's an old test and Old Testament
names for enemies of gods
people the nations of gog and magog were
enemies of god's people and they gather
together to battle against god and fire
comes down from god out of heaven
after this white throne judgment and
they are devoured and cast into the lake
of fire second death so they're the
saved all the save they're saved that
happens at the second coming
you still there Cade yes pastor I'm
sorry for additional question does it
mean only Christians like if there will
be other people who are from other
nations are the tongs who did not know
good oh I see what you're saying now
there yeah I've just got a few seconds
so let me see if I can answer this
quickly and this is it we're just going
to take a break here in a minute but
there will be some people no doubt that
will be saved who maybe did not know the
gospel of course before Jesus came
there's all these people in the Old
Testament times and Jesus said many will
come from the east and the west and sit
down in the kingdom with Abraham Isaac
and Jacob but those people are saved at
the same time when Christ comes they're
under the blood of the Lamb everyone is
saved by Christ but some maybe did not
know everything but they lived up to
what they know we've got more we're
gonna learn about this another subject
friends we're just taking a break and I
catch our breath get a drink you can
call your friends tell them tune in
we'll be right back with more questions
stay tuned Bible answers live will
return shortly
[Music]
if you enjoy hearing solid biblical
answers on Bible answers live you can
have those same insights at your
fingertips through the amazing facts
prophecy Study Bible the updated
hardcover version is available at its
lowest price ever and includes the
complete set of amazing facts 27 study
guides plus a Bible numbers and symbols
chart and eight pages of colorful maps
this best-ever Bible gives you a
biblical cyclope dhic index words of
Christ in red chronology of the Old
Testament
along with Doug bachelors how to study
the Bible feature and much more call us
at AF bookstore to learn more about it
at one eight hundred five three eight
seventy two seventy five the amazing
facts prophecy study Bible stance apart
from other Bibles giving you the same
solid answers you hear each week on
Bible answers live order your copy today
at AF bookstore calm or by calling 1-800
five three eight seventy two seventy
five
what if you could know the future what
would you do
what would you change to see the future
you must understand the past Alexander
the Great becomes king when he's only 18
but he's a military prodigy a hundred
and fifty years in advance Cyrus had
been named wrong was violent they were
ruthless they were determined the Gospel
writers see his death as a fulfillment
of salvation this intriguing documentary
hosted by Pastor Doug Batchelor explores
the most striking bible prophecies that
have been dramatically fulfilled
throughout history kingdoms in time get
your copy today available now on DVD
blu-ray or USB for more information
visit kingdoms in time.com
you're listening to Bible answers live
where every question answered provides a
clearer picture of God and his plan to
save you so what are you waiting for
get practical answers about the good
book for a better life today
if you have a question about the Bible
or living the Christian life call us now
at 800-831-6273
you want to see what we look like in our
studio I don't know why in the world
anyone would but some people seem to
enjoy it so you can take a look and see
what it radio looks like that sounds
like a contradiction my name is Doug
Batchelor my name is John Ross and we
gonna go to our second part of our
program beginning with Jerry who's
listening in Texas Jerry welcome to the
program oh good evening evening oh guy
yeah well thank you for calling your
question tonight oh yes just a quick
thing that I don't think that there's I
probably are you a master answer to my
question but is there any archaeological
evidence to say that Nebuchadnezzar took
a seven-year radiation you know that's a
good question Jerry I will not pretend
that I am acquainted with all the
historical information on the babylonian
kings i don't remember ever reading
anything from history i think that it's
very likely the the fact that he was
able to retain power indicates that
probably the court the palace personnel
to protect because if if one king lost
power then someone else filled the
vacuum and they would probably all be
fired or executed and they probably did
a pretty good job of trying to hide that
he had been incapacitated you know i
right now at the time of this recording
seems like there's a lot of secrecy
about what's happened to the leader of
North Korea nobody wants to know about
his medical condition and America came
into power when King George the 3rd
seemed to go bonkers and they tried to
hide that for several years so it
probably wouldn't be much in history
because he did end up getting his wits
and his power back he probably didn't
want the historical records outside of
what he wrote in the Bible to say yeah I
was out of my mind like a raving lunatic
for seven years it doesn't build
confidence when the King says that and
also you know I read somewhere about
back in the time of Babylon there was a
certain amount of superstition that if
you treated a mad person badly you could
receive their madness so it's quite
possible that they you know kind of
separate anything from you know the
regular crowd and the royal palace but
they kind of took care for it took care
of him as much as they could the other
thing is of course Daniel was very
prominent in Babylon at the time he knew
about the dream he already interpreted
to the king he knew that this is going
to be a seven year period someone to
maybe Daniel played a role in kind of
keeping the threads a good point
funny I believe this Prime Minister he
probably helped him preserve power yeah
great question Jerry thanks for calling
annexed calling is also from Texas we
have la Nonna calling Leo yeah welcome I
had a question I was reading Hebrews and
I wanted to know what the order of
Melchisedec um how how it pertains can
be well I'll say a little bit pastor
Ross loves Hebrews and I'll let him add
to that Melchizedek is a character who
appears in Genesis he's called the king
priests of Salem now the same territory
is later known as Jerusalem Abraham
gives him tithe from a battle he had won
against the the Syrians to the north a
king named Chedorlaomer and then in
Hebrews Paul is making an analogy in the
saying that Melchizedek is the leader of
even even greater priesthood than
Aaron because Abraham the father of the
Levites and Aaron he paid tithe to
Melchizedek and he says Jesus is a
symbol of Melchizedek that he's a
greater priesthood and that everything
about Christianity is better is what
it's saying yeah absolutely I think Paul
we believe Paul wrote Hebrews is making
the case that Jesus is a greater priest
than the Levitical priesthood because
the Jews would say well Jesus from the
tribe of Judah he couldn't be a priest
you know priests had to come from the
tribe of Levi and so then Paul is
illustrating a different priesthood
other than that of the Levitical
priesthood which is even greater than
that and it describes it as the
Melchizedek Priesthood now Kazuki's
boast both a priest and a king so that
was somewhat unique Christ through the
kingly line he's from Judah but the
priestly line is even greater than that
of the Levitical priesthood and Paul
makes this analogy with Melchizedek
interesting character we don't have a
lot written about him in the Old
Testament but he does pop up a few times
in the New Testament that's right I
think even Psalms mentions Melchizedek
yep thank you very much hope that helps
you know we need to write a little book
about who was Melchizedek that would be
we get a lot of good questions on that
absolutely we call Mike listening in st.
Louis Mike welcome to the program hey
how you guys doing
we're always better than we deserve well
that's good how are you doing I can't
complain um my question actually comes
from watching your show that's how I
came up with it but here it is um let me
throw my glasses well real quick I wrote
it down so I wouldn't stumble on it
alright um here it is um does Revelation
chapter 7 verses 6 & 8 and James chapter
1 verse 1 show that only two tribes
became lost before the time of Christ
and were replaced by making Manasseh a
half tribe a full tribe replacing they
have tribe of Ephraim and Joseph a new
tribe replacing Dan okay that's a good
question Mike and you're a deep thinker
you're looking at the 12 tribes that are
mentioned that composed 144,000 in
Revelation chapter 7 it is a unique list
the tribes were the sons of Jacob
Jacob's name was changed to Israel so
when you say the tribes of Jacob the
tribes of Israel it's the same character
he had 12 sons but because Joseph was
sold by his brothers when Jacob was
reunited with Joseph he said look Joseph
I'm gonna treat your two sons their
names were ephraim and manasseh like my
sons they're gonna get an equal share
because you were alienated from the
family for over 30 years and so they end
up becoming numbered but over history
the that tribes in the north there was a
civil war between the ten tribes in the
north and with the priests which were
the Levites and the two tribes in the
south Benjamin and Judah and ten of
those tribes were carried off captive by
the Assyrians they never had a big
return the tribes of Judah and Benjamin
when they were carried the babel and
they did come back so 10 of those tribes
largely evaporated so when you're
talking about the 12 tribes in
Revelation it must be using symbolic
names every name in Revelation
practically is symbolic I think once or
twice it talks about Jesus and then John
talks about John those are literal but
every other name in Revelation it talks
about you know the dragon and Michael
and a Pauline and Balaam and Jezebel and
all those names are symbolic we believe
the 12 tribes that are mentioned here
really are highlighting the the plan of
salvation and you know who God is going
to save from both Israel and the church
now I've got a book I wrote on that and
we'll send you a free copy that gives a
lot more detail if you'd like that Mike
it's called who are the hundred and
forty-four thousand and the number to
call for that he's eight hundred eight
three five six seven four seven and he
get asked to the book called who 144,000
that's eight hundred eight three five
six seven four seven and it's free just
add to that a little bit during the time
of Jesus you ask
any of the tribes came back during the
time of Jesus we find that the Jews were
referred to as Jews Jews were primarily
from the descendants of Judah right and
of course we know Saul who later became
Paul was from the tribe of Benjamin
Benjamin was a much smaller tribe and
the Levites they didn't receive an
inheritance so they were scattered
amongst the all of the twelve tribes but
they were consecrated more so closer to
Jerusalem and of course that served as
the capital of the two tribes in the
south so there's a little background on
that
thanks your call Mike we've got Henry
listening from Bronx New York Henry
welcome to the program yeah how are you
doing one question that I asked listen I
want to know it stayed in the Bible
whether that's written in there that no
thing no single going punished why
didn't God make it so we're people who
were who didn't over their lives while
they're live why didn't you why didn't
he he didn't do anything to until they
didn't they come Ben death when we
really gonna do it
all right good question I appreciate
that Henry all sinned there's
consequences for all sin now if God
punished all sin instantly the penalty
for sin is death that would mean the
first time a person sinned
shortly after their age of
accountability they would vaporize
they'd die or whatever judgment God
would pick nobody would ever even live
long enough to have mercy to have
probation to understand the plan of
salvation so God is merciful and he's
very patient and he bears long even with
the wicked there are consequences for
our sins even during our lives but
instead of God giving everybody the
death penalty when we sin he chastens us
in different ways to try to get our
attention that might mean some physical
suffering it might mean a financial
reverse it might mean problems in the
family depends on what the scene is
it might mean time in jail you know
their God does punish sin now sometimes
it looks like people are getting away
with murder and some in the world are
guilty of murder for a long time all
those things are going to be justified
in the judgement the Lord says vengeance
is mine I will repay nobody gets away
with anything God is not mocked whatever
a man so is he's going to reap but the
Lord is merciful in this life trying to
get people to come to repentance before
their lives are over because once you
die it says after that the judgment
there's no more second chance after
death you know pastor Doug in a very
real sense we do read to a certain
degree what we saw here on this earth if
somebody is unhealthy
they eat bad they don't take care of
their body maybe they take a whole lot
of different types of drugs or chemicals
their life is gonna be shorter than
someone probably who eats well and takes
care of their life and they probably
wanted the peace or the joy somebody who
has broken down relationships and caused
the division there's not much peace or
joy in that so yes in a very real sense
people do reap what they sow even now
but ultimately you have the judgment
yeah and we have a lesson I'd like to
send you that gives more detail on that
Henry it's free it's called case closed
it's on the great Judgment Day of God
and you know there's a verse I think
I've been Ecclesiastes and I forget
where it is but it it basically says
those sentence against an evil work is
not executed speedily therefore the
hearts of the sons of men are fully set
in them to do evil because God is
merciful and he doesn't app us with
lightning every time we sin people
sometimes presume on God's grace I think
we've all been guilty of that at times
but there is a Judgment Day for all all
will stand before the judgment seat of
Christ please anyone who wants to
understand what the Bible says about the
judgment most people aren't lining up
for this lessons that they need you they
need you
it's called case closed the number to
call 808 three five six seven four seven
and again the lesson is called case
closed and it talks about what does the
Bible say about judgment now for the
believer it's not a fearful thing but it
is a sobering thought and we'd encourage
people to take a look at that
we've got Julie listening in California
Julie welcome to the program
[Music]
so I have a question about first
Thessalonians chapter 4 verses basically
13 through 17 I'm a little confused
about where it says for this we declare
to you that you were to read that verse
yeah yeah all right so I'll start with
verse 13 but I and this is first
Thessalonians 4 and verse 13 but I do
not want you to be ignorant brethren
concerning those who have fallen asleep
Paul's talking about death lest you
sorrow as others that have no hope
Christians don't have to worry because
there's a resurrection for if we believe
that Jesus died and rose again even so
God will bring with him those who sleep
in Jesus for this we say to you by the
word of the Lord that the Lord Lord that
we who are alive and remain until the
coming of the Lord will by no means
precede that means we won't go before
those who have fallen asleep for the
Lord Himself will descend from heaven
with a shout with the voice of an
archangel and with the trumpet of God
and the dead in Christ will rise first
then we who are alive he said so first
their rise they rise they get their
glorified bodies they they are
resurrected then we who are alive and
remain will be caught up together with
them in the clouds to meet the Lord in
the air and thus we shall always be with
the Lord and so does that a what
anything specific about that that I read
yes okay so I'm confused about this
Jesus well God will bring with him those
who have fallen asleep I I was always
under the impression through my studies
that that we won't rise to heaven until
the second coming yeah well let me let
me give you a picture I think I know
what you're asking let me paint this
with words so when the Lord comes back
his feet don't touch the ground first
thing he does as he's sweeping around
the circle of the earth he resurrects
the dead in Christ
they are caught up with their glorified
bodies they are then with the Lord then
after they're gathered we who are alive
and remain will be caught up together so
it's not that they've been raised
thousands of years earlier they're being
raised at the second coming but they're
raised first before we are transformed
to caught up to meet them you know
another thing on this verse which could
be a little confusing it says for if we
believe that Jesus died and rose again
even so God will bring with him those
who sleep in Jesus we're kind of
thinking in this first from our
perspective that somehow Jesus is going
to bring with him those who sleep or God
will bring with Jesus those who sleep
but really the verse is from God's
perspective in heaven so Jesus comes he
gathers up the redeemed and he's gonna
bring them with him back to God back to
heaven back to right the home of the
redeemed so it's not from our
perspective but here Paul he's
describing from God's perspective he's
gonna saying Jesus Jesus is gonna gather
them up and bring them back to him okay
so but why does it say that make no
mistake we will not precede them precede
them yeah why would it say that instead
of saying they will not precede it I
think Paul was trying to comfort he said
you're not gonna get to heaven and find
their loved ones aren't there so don't
worry there so I together see this is
the key word look at verse 17 then we
who are alive and remain will be caught
up together with them in the clouds not
in heaven we're all gonna get together
at the second coming to meet the Lord in
the air together with him and thus shall
we them in us and the Lord always be
together so we're to comfort each other
that we're not going to be eternal
separated he's giving them simply the
sequence of the resurrection can we send
you a lesson on this Julie we've got a
lesson that covers this whole whole
passage the the lesson is called
ultimate deliverance and we'll send this
to anyone who asked the number is 800
eight three five six seven four seven
and again you can answer that study
guide is called ultimate deliverance and
we will be happy to send this to anyone
who calls we've got a caller Joseph
listening from Abu Dhabi Joseph welcome
to the program hey good evening
hi thank you for calling I've been to
Abu Dhabi a couple of times
Oh wonderful give testimony and your
question do you remember in Revelation
chapter 12
it's things about the ten horns which
are ten Kings and I have recently come
across an interpretation it says they
have not yet received the kingdom which
means it cannot be the ten divisions of
ancient Roman Empire because it says
they have not received that Kingdom yet
so it's something that's yet to come in
the future from our perspective okay
well I'll share real quick I think
pastor Ross might have something to say
on this but when you're reading John
when you're reading revelation from
John's perspective this is in the future
at the time when the woman in you have a
woman in revelation 17 and she's riding
a beast with these 10 10 horns they were
not in power with individual kingdoms at
that time that didn't happen until later
on so again it's just from whose
perspective the angel is explaining
these symbols to John and the kingdoms
that are the ten horns the ten kings
that under the kingdom there's other
places in the Bible that identify them
as being the divisions of Western Europe
however it does say in verse 12 they
receive authority one hour as Kings with
the Beast now of course we understand
that for a period of about twelve
hundred and sixty years during the Dark
Ages the beasts power was sort of
influencing these kingdoms this one hour
is yet in the future where we have
church and state uniting and passing
certain laws restricting worship so that
is still a future future fulfillment
there we'd ever
I called the other woman which is all
about Revelation chapter 17 true and if
you haven't read that Joseph I think
you'll enjoy it I the number to call for
those in North America of course you can
read it online the number for those here
in North America is eight hundred eight
three five six seven four seven as for
the study guide called the other woman
we've got David listening from Guam we
went from the east now all the way over
to the west David welcome to the program
are you doing pastor good thank you for
calling we got a couple minutes left so
we better get our question pretty quick
okay I got a question here that I'm just
kind of curious because when when God
made a man you know Eve was the first
one and then he brought out an Adam but
then for the rest of that time when did
all these different colors of skin
started come about do you know it yeah
oh I'm sorry yeah we always pull the
volume down when we're answering it
makes it a little better audio but I
think I got the question you know
anthropologists sometimes divide the
races in the world into three primary
races but actually there are hundreds of
different combinations of races around
the planet and when you get to the Tower
of Babel of course all the people from
Noah and they they're the only people
that populate it or repopulated the
earth they ended up making this great
tower they are in the plains of Shinar
and God you know confounded their work
and they were scattered and dispersed
everywhere and so all of the different
nations and races fanned out from
Mesopotamia and it's interesting that
the the DNA mapping that they do of the
world and the migration of man they've
got two theories they say that all of
the all of the peoples of the world can
be traced back to northeast Africa or or
in Mesopotamia now of course the Bible
says its Mesopotamia that from there all
the different races fanned out as
different people groups centered in
different parts of the world and they
were separated by
and oceans they would intermarry with
their basically their same people and so
certain genetic traits became more
predominant and that's where you get the
different races yeah I think it's
important to note that you know all
irrespective of the color of your skin
of your race your all are the same
number of DNA and there are certain
abilities within DNA where certain genes
are in recess and other genes are more
active determining the color of your
skin your eyes your hair there's a
number of reasons but all of us have the
genetic information God has given each
person through Adam and Eve this
flexibility as families move different
environmental situations change certain
genes become prominent but it doesn't
matter who you are you've got the
genetic material that traces all the way
back to Adam unless the Bible says God
has created all nations from one blood
that's right we are all related you know
we have time for maybe half a question
if you can pick someone all right well
let's try up well let's see uh so some
of yeah there we go Maria is listening
Hawaii Maria welcome to the program all
right
good question you know what do you do if
you're Christian you know Jesus is
coming is it wrong to have some money in
savings whether it's a you know a
retirement account or a 401k you know
it's a balance and then now there may be
a time before the Lord comes where he's
going to impress people hey we're near
the end a good time to invest everything
in God's kingdom or give heavily but you
know John Wesley said every Christian
ought to save all he can earn all he can
there's nothing wrong with making good
investments Jesus in the parable of the
talents encourages people to work with
their their talents and their gifts to
multiply them and then give all you can
save all you can earn all you can give
all you can I don't recommend I've known
a few people in history
they're Christians that get excited
about conditions in the world they sell
all their assets thinking the world's
about to end and they you know all of us
want to make sure we have nothing left
when Jesus comes we've invested
everything in the kingdom but then all
of a sudden the world continues going on
things settle down and now they have no
retirement and they become a burden to
their families and and they think well
maybe I was getting a little excited
liquidating everything so you need to
pray you know I've got to be careful not
to tell people how to make financial
investments continue to pay faithfully
do Tides offerings when mission
opportunities present themselves but I
would not tell a Christian to make no
plans for the future because I think
there are scriptures that say it's
probably a prudent thing to to be saving
some for the future and for retirement
so anything you want to add to that yeah
I was just going to say this probably
number of individuals in the last
hundred years that went through
different experiences where they thought
this is the end and of course here we
are today so it's not a denial of faith
to make wise financial decisions I mean
ultimately when Jesus comes all of this
is not going to be worth anything I
think if we're seeking God's will he
will guide us as to when it is like you
mentioned that he might want to sell
everything and invest in the Lord's work
yeah when God poured out the spirit
during Pentecost that says they then
knew they were liquidating and putting
everything into the kingdom I think
God's gonna pour out his Spirit again
before he comes in will we're also gonna
know hey friends thank you so much it's
been a delight studying the Word of God
with you we've got a few very important
announcements we'd like to hear and
closing most of all keep in mind Jesus
is coming soon and we want to live by
every word
thank you for listening to today's
broadcast
we hope you understand your Bible even
better than before Bible answers live is
produced by amazing facts International
a faith-based ministry located in
Granite Bay California terror attacks
natural disasters political instability
and global economic meltdown these are
the images people generally associate
with the tribulation and the day of the
Lord but did you know the Bible speaks
about another day of the Lord just
before the great Judgment Day amazingly
imprinted on the very fabric of time
itself is a 24-hour period called the
Sabbath that was meant to forever be a
time of restoration for every human
being a day the entire world is largely
forgotten you'll be surprised to learn
how this special day of the Lord
factors in the last day prophecies such
as the mark of the beast the seal of God
and the great final tribulation it's all
contained in this new eye-opening DVD
series called the last day of prophecy
to order call 800 538 7 to 75 or visit
AF bookstore com can't get enough
amazing facts Bible study you don't have
to wait until next week to enjoy more
truth filled programming visit the
amazing facts media library at aft vor G
at aft vor G you can enjoy video and
audio presentations as well as printed
material all free of charge 24 hours a
day seven days a week right from your
computer or mobile device visit aft vo
RG DT no amazing backs has a free Bible
school that you can do from the comfort
of your own home it includes 27
beautifully illustrated study lessons to
aid in your study of God's Word sign up
today for this free Bible study course
by calling 184 257,000 that's one eight
forty four two one five seven thousand
[Music]
for life-changing Christian resources
visit AF bookstore calm
[Music]
if you'd like to enhance your study of
God's Word visit our website at
www.ge.com which offers thousands of
inspiring books DVDs and more to help
you get the most out of God's Word to
take advantage of the offers you've
heard on this broadcast
call us at $887 RG
[Music]